i'm sure by now that most of us are  familiar with king leonidas and that  famous spartan kick but what if i told  you there was someone in greek mythology  who was spartan kicking people off  cliffs for fun there was an outlaw who  went by the name of skiron who used to  rob people when they passed a set of  rocks by the sea but taking their  belongings wasn't enough he would then  force them to wash his feet i know what  you're thinking what an a-hole but it  gets worse as they knelt down to begin  scrubbing his feet he would then just  randomly kick them off the cliff into  the sea below those who didn't die  immediately would be eaten by a giant  monstrous sea turtle eventually this  spartan kicking thief met his match when  he encountered the hero theseus when he  tried to steal from theseus he grabbed  skiron by his extremely clean feet swung  him around and threw him off the cliff  just like he had done to so many others